what I'm interested in is that you've
been there you studied the gulag you
wrote about
you wrote about Eichmann you seen what's
going on in your area of the world and
you know so many things for your movie
so the big question who is that evil
comes from what is it that by experience
or by your study you start to understand
about that about evil you know I think
again I would begin with you know your
your idea that barbarianism has somehow
come back and I would argue that it
never went away and that and I would
pick up on this point about
dehumanization that a couple of people
have alluded to and I and and the point
about power because the the human
instinct to make oneself better by
making others worse by diminishing by
destroying by dehumanizing other people
seems to me very profound and I don't
have a I don't have an anthropological
or a psychological explanation for it
but even as some of you have been
mentioning some of the things that have
been done around the world I hear echoes
you know you're you know being being
told that your language is not important
well when Hitler came into Poland one of
the things he did was he told people
they weren't allowed to speak polish and
so for example my father-in-law
speaks German while he's passed away but
he spoke some German because when he was
a child and he went to school he was not
allowed to speak polish in school he
could only speak German that was the
occupying language when the Soviet Union
was seeking to Soviet eyes Ukraine
starting in the 1930s what did they do
they eliminated the language and so the
attempt to eliminate other cultures
through eliminating language or through
eliminating symbols or through
eliminating religion or through
downplaying our religion is better than
yours and incidentally the word religion
I'm not I I have mixed feelings about
because you know although I do believe
that of course the acts that we saw in
Paris last night were connected to
radical Islam and they involve an
interpretation they are an
interpretation of Islam I think there
that's very different from saying that
they're about really
I mean you you know the you know it was
it's is you know the radical communism
you know the Bolshevism that was used to
excuse the murder of millions of people
had a lot in common linguistically with
the language of the the moderate left I
mean if you if you lay sometimes read
the same texts you know people read
Marxism marks on the in the central left
and they read it in the Soviet Union but
the interpretation of it and the way in
which it was used to gain and maintain
and hold power and discriminate against
enemies was very specific so the the
radical Islamists use of religion in a
specific way which is very similar to
the to the to the Nazi use of national
ideas or the Soviet use of communist
ideas this is the impulse that that
connects these things not you know
religion isn't in that sense isn't
different I mean it's a it's another
this is this is the contemporary form of
expressing that kind of fanaticism but
we've seen it before and many of the
techniques and patterns are very similar
so you know I you know I'm not I'm not
equipped I'm not I'm not a theologian as
Isis or a psychiatrist but I mean
clearly there is something that is
innate you know that human beings does
there's a there's a there are some
people who desire to think in this way
and it has expressed itself in different
forms in different times and it doesn't
go away and the only thing we can do is
find a moderate language in which to
speak about it and to try to create
political institutions and incentives
and which which reduce its which reduce
its range and we did do that in Europe
after the Second World War and we did
have an alternate ideology and we did
have an alternate way of thinking and
the question is whether that was is now
strong enough to motivate new
generations or not I think we can do a
little bit more we can stop to accept
every explanation we are so eager to
understand what happened that we are
listen very carefully to the explanation
a person give to us
and we tried to be psychologists or no I
don't wanna know but but we are
explanations are very welcome and to
hear the reasons of a perpetrator is
something we like why why couldn't we
say don't you dare tell me that there is
a reason for this act for this behavior
we have to deny some explanations we
have to say people no sorry there is no
explanation for specialties and we have
no concentration on don't look for the
explenation you shall have solutions
yes you have to listen to this
explanation if you have also so many
people excluded people frustrated people
people this is a basis also fulfil what
do you call babbles yes but it is a
difference to have a scientific interest
in two explanations and to find the
origins of evil and so high questions
but to deal with special yet even young
people young people need to know what is
a real explanation and what is not what
is a true way to think and only a way to
refuse justifications or responsibility
and it's it's a we have we asked what
can we do and it's not only a question
of sign I have some people of my best
friend how do you associate Paraguay's
and of course first of all was Isis but
very many also identified with the
tabloids with the modern TV with
behavior of the 10 of clubs sporting
clubs this is also burdened in in
customs in Hades which is in a way it
could be a step to another barbers but
also what you are saying is that and I
agree with you that barbarism is such a
ridiculously inflated word that is used
is deployed against people we don't like
this morning for breakfast we had some
pop music for about three minutes and I
thought how why don't they stop this
barbaric music you know as I was reading
on my iPad about the really barbaric
events which had gone on in in in Paris
so you know we do have this very generic
word but we need explanations I'm sorry
my job let me finish my job is to find
explanations not justifications I don't
need a job to justify or not justify can
condemn like everybody else okay this is
a human right but my job is to try to
find explanation why is it that these
people whether it's a small group or
whether it's the Gulag or Nazi Germany
or something and here we have two
different technologies of evil what you
call state induced which in a way let's
take it a bit more cultural induced you
are part of a culture which justifies
whatever it is that that you do you're a
conformist you're a part of a group and
then the other kind of evil you are a
nonconformist you go completely against
the grain the people who did what they
did last night
we're both we're conforming to what they
thought was an ideology and therefore
taking enormous self-satisfaction
presumably because they were part of
this grandiose project and so on and at
the same time they were acting like anti
Bulls ROM terrorists saying oh look what
we are doing we're going to scare all of
you we are going to you know you're
we're going to change France wow you
know what a fantastic moment of power if
also it was a so yeah well you call it
Bolshevik
you know frankly go back in history it's
just you know it's one after the other
it is absolutely unfortunately nothing
new what one of the bad things about the
historian being a historian and why many
people don't like us really is because
because we are terribly boring because
because commentator and social
scientists and journalists and so on
says this is a new thing this has never
happened before and we arrive and we say
it actually happened before you know how
how tedious you know what once there was
a fish scientist I'm sure it made up who
thought that the goldfish going around a
particular thing would you keep the bowl
a bowl you know takes about seven
seconds and because their memory seven
seconds they have a most fantastic life
because they keep on saying wow I've
never been here this is really exciting
and the historian is a fish with an
eight second memory goes behind this is
there you were there seven second ago
you were saying but but sometimes
historians I'm only a philosopher so I
can say but sometimes historians are so
eager to find examples fitting to that
theories that they are not able to see
new things and I think I think the a new
problem dealing with explanation is that
we have very intelligent and experienced
liars they knew our love to wisdom our
love to explanations our curiosity our
will to understand they are able to give
us explanations we want to hear my case
are 5-1 perfect example for it he knew
perfectly well what people want to see
and wanted to hear and they gave it to
them and even the most cleverest people
fall into the trap
of this lies so I think we should talk a
bit more about our expectations what
what could be an explanation for evil
and we want to understand it we really
want to understand it and this makes us
sometimes weak
you